Вона вдумлива, доброзичлива людина. І Анґела Меркель - лідер,
а не той, хто просто слідує за іншими.
Я вважаю її чуйною людиною. Вона порядна, без вагань прямує шляхом,
який вважає правильним. Однак у нас різні думки про те,
що таке правильний шлях.
От якби я намагався описати її одним словом - так, прагматичність,
раціональність, що, як мені здається, для політики взагалі - непогана риса.
Вона дуже сильна і рішуча жінка.
Але цю силу, яка їй дана, використовує для натхнення,
а не для залякування. Вона об'єднує людей, а не нацьковує їх один на одного.
Вона вирішує проблеми і справляється з важкими ситуаціями.
Її вміння ділитися голою правдою з власним народом -
це блискуча здатність у політиці. У цьому й полягає успіх пані Меркель.
Пані Меркель не складна в спілкуванні. Її легко зрозуміти.
Вона поводиться шанобливо і вимагає поваги до себе.
Вольова, непохитна, рішуча.
Ніхто не може заперечувати політичну компетентність Анґели Меркель,
її політичні навички. Вона - блискучий тактик.
Чого їй не вистачало, на мій погляд, то це стратегічного бачення.
Я ціную її як витвір мистецтва, який об'єднав у собі безліч різноманітних граней.
Це означає, що депутатка доктор Анґела Меркель
обрана першою жінкою-канцлеркою Федеративної Республіки Німеччина
необхідною більшістю голосів німецьких парламентарів.
Жінка, яка провела свою юність в авторитарній системі.
І раптом вона стає канцлеркою демократичної вільної країни.
І дозвольте запитати Вас, чи готові Ви прийняти ваше обрання?
Пане голово, я приймаю обрання.
Було очевидно, що у неї дуже сильний характер.
І що її легко її недооцінити. Тому я був упевнений, що у неї
все вийде, і сказав своїм людям тоді, що вона залишиться на своєму посту
надовго. Але я і гадки не мав, НАСКІЛЬКИ довго.
Анґела Меркель, народилася в Гамбурзі 17 липня 1954 року.
Виросла в НДР, куди її батьки переїхали незабаром після її народження.
Закінчила середню школу в 1973 році,
потім вивчала фізику в Лейпцигу, у 1986-му отримала докторський ступінь.
Після падіння Берлінського муру прийшла в політику і стала заступницею
прессекретаря керівника першого і останнього вільно обраного
уряду НДР - Лотара де Мезьєра.
Після возз'єднання Німеччини в грудні 1990 року вона стає депутаткою Бундестагу
від правлячої партії ХДС, перемігши на виборах у своєму виборчому окрузі.
За сприяння тодішнього канцлера Німеччини Гельмута Коля вона
в 1991 році стає федеральною міністеркою у справах жінок і молоді.
З 1994 по 1998 рік Меркель - федеральна міністерка з охорони довкілля.
Недооцінена багатьма, нагороджена прізвиськом "дівчинки Коля",
вона стає генеральною секретаркою партії після поразки ХДС
на федеральних виборах 1998 року,
а ще через півтора року - головою партії.
Я приймаю обрання.
У 2005 році консервативний блок висуває її кандидаткою в канцлери,
і вона перемагає чинного голову уряду ФРН Ґергарда Шредера.
У віці 51 року її обирають канцлеркою. Вона - наймолодша керівниця уряду в історії ФРН.
Хто міг уявити собі таке, пані та панове?
Задля зустрічей з главами іноземних держав та урядів за час свого канцлерства
Анґела Меркель долає на літаках сотні тисяч миль.
Відносини з наймогутнішою країною світу – США - мають для канцлерки
особливе значення. У середині січня 2006 року
вона вперше зустрічається з тодішнім президентом США Джорджем Бушем-молодшим.
Моє перше враження після 45 хвилин в Овальному кабінеті
було неймовірно позитивним.
Вона розумна, дуже здібна, у неї є сила духу, яка вабить,
вона любить свободу.
А тепер я запрошую її на обід.
Взаєморозуміння між Меркель і Бушем виникло,
можна сказати, з першого погляду.
Куди більш прохолодними стануть відносини з іншим впливовим
главою держави, якого вона вперше відвідає в Москві три дні по тому
і з яким їй доведеться мати справу протягом усього свого канцлерства:
Володимир Путін.
Путін вільно розмовляє німецькою, нова канцлерка прекрасно
володіє російською. Здавалося б, ніщо не стояло на шляху до взаєморозуміння.
Ну, так нам здавалося. Тоді.
Але, природно, потім з'ясувалося, що знання мови і навіть
знання країни - це не достатнє багатство,
хоча і необхідна умова для того, щоб зберегти
і розвинути ось ці особливі відносини між Росією і Німеччиною.
Буквально через півроку російський президент приймає глав держав та урядів
економічно найбільш розвинених демократій світу на саміті G8 у Росії.
Анґела Меркель уперше бере участь у форумі такого високого рівня.
Коли вона приїхала на свій перший великий саміт у Санкт-Петербург,
вона була просто дуже спокійною, висловлювалася максимально ясно.
Тож ніхто і ніколи не намагався посунути її ліктем на цих самітах.
Вона володіє таким спокійним авторитетом, який діє досить ефективно.
Я б не називав це справжнім масажем, я б назвав це свого роду
спонтанним вираженням дружби.
І я впевнений, що люди не знали, що з цим робити.
Анґело, прости, що я так вчинив.
Через це ти опинилася в центрі уваги, але, з іншого боку,
це вислів мого дружнього ставлення до тебе.
За 16 років на чолі уряду Анґелі Меркель багато разів
доведеться стикатися з впливовими людьми.
Такими як Володимир Путін, який намагався вивести її з рівноваги
за допомогою своєї собаки. З впертим Дональдом Трампом.
І турецьким президентом-автократом Реджепом Ердоганом.
Анґела Меркель довела, поза всяких сумнівів,
що володіє дивовижною здатністю виснажувати своїх опонентів.
Особливо чоловіків, які схильні недооцінювати її через те, що вона жінка.
Я думаю, що канцлерка Меркель значною мірою вийшла за межі гендерних дебатів.
Її вплив дійсно домінує при розмові з нею і заглушає будь-які розмови про те, що значить бути жінкою.
У червні 2007 року канцлерка вперше приймає саміт "Великої вісімки" в Німеччині.
На балтійському курорті Гайлігендамм вона намагається знайти рішення для низки глобальних проблем разом зі своїми впливовими гостями.
Морське повітря - дуже чисте, воно приводить думки до ладу.
І, можливо, це допоможе вам сконцентруватися на головному.
Незважаючи на всю дружелюбність, Анґела Меркель зустрічає опір.
Вона хоче, щоб глави держав і урядів взяли на себе зобов'язання щодо більш активного захисту клімату.
Однак президент США Буш гальмує обговорення теми скорочення викидів парникових газів.
Меркель прагне гармонії. Утім, до неї не дослухаються ще з одного питання -
особливо Джордж Буш і Тоні Блер - про необхідність посилення регулювання фінансових ринків.
На початку складалось враження, що це природна катастрофа, але все-таки мав місце людський фактор.
Всього два місяці по тому в США лопається бульбашка на ринку нерухомості,
сотні тисяч американців втрачають свої будинки, частина банківської системи зазнає краху.
Адміністрація США вливає 700 мільярдів доларів у фінансовий сектор. Занадто пізно.
Криза стрімко охоплює всю світову фінансову систему - в тому числі європейський і німецький банківські сектори.
Восени 2008 року Анґела Меркель зіткнулася з першим серйозним глобальним викликом і опинилася в ролі кризового менеджера.
Ситуація на міжнародних фінансових ринках серйозна. У такій формі вона безпрецедентна.
Вона ставить під сумнів багато з того, що вважалося цілком очевидним.
Європейський Союз піддається першому стрестесту з моменту вступу Меркель на посаду: фінансова криза переростає в економічну.
Президент Франції Ніколя Саркозі хоче, аби всі країни ЄС спільно спробували зміцнити банки і терміново здійснили грошові вливання в економіку.
Анґела Меркель вважає, що потрібні національні рішення і стримує французького лідера.
Що мене іноді дратувало, дуже сильно дратувало, то це те, що вона вагалася, коли справа доходила до великих європейських рішень.
Тому що як фізик-науковець вона завжди намагалася все прорахувати від початку до кінця.
Коли світові спекулянти починають всерйоз придивлятися до європейських держав з високою заборгованістю,
стабільність спільної валюти євро раптово опиняється під загрозою. Зокрема, під приціл потрапляє Греція.
Адже в жовтні 2009 року новий прем'єр-міністр Греції Георгіос Папандреу був змушений визнати,
що насправді борги країни значно більші, ніж було відомо раніше.
Країна навряд чи може дозволити собі нові позики, їй загрожує неплатоспроможність і банкрутство.
Греції терміново потрібна допомога. І знову Анґела Меркель не поспішає з рішеннями.
З тими, хто зазнає найбільших труднощів, з тими, звичайно, ми будемо говорити про те, як нам зберегти стабільність євро.
Меркель не хоче давати Греції фінансову допомогу на початковому етапі і вимагає, щоб греки допомогли собі самі.
Вона не хоче використовувати гроші німецьких платників податків. Така позиція забезпечила їй підтримку передусім у Німеччині.
Найголовніше, чого вона не зробила, це те, що вона не пояснила німецькому суспільству, що зберегти валютний союз - в його ж інтересах.
Пам'ятаєте? Німецька громадськість майже нічого не відчула під час фінансової кризи.
Ми не повинні забувати, що саме ідіотизм таких банків як Deutsche Bank, Société Générale та BNP Paribas і став причиною катастрофи - кризи євро.
І Меркель рятувала їх, цинічно перекладаючи всі ці втрати на плечі платників податків.
Вона увійде в історію як канцлерка, яка дозволила цьому статися і назвала все це солідарністю з греками,
іспанцями, ірландцями, хоча насправді це було не так.
Коли стає ясно, що Греції загрожує національне банкрутство, а інші країни ЄС також перебувають у скрутному становищі,
Анґела Меркель погоджується на величезний пакет допомоги.
У Європейському Союзі розгорається запекла суперечка - в тому числі з Грецією.
Анґела Меркель хоче, щоб уряд Греції в обмін на фінансову допомогу вжив заходів, спрямованих на масштабну економію коштів.
Це, в свою чергу, призводить до серйозного скорочення соціального сектора в Греції і викликає численні бурхливі протести.
Анґела Меркель завойовує там репутацію крижаної німкені.
Як переконаний європеєць, я хотів би, щоб і вона була палкою європейкою.
Для того, щоб об'єднати континент.
Замість цього вона дозволила - можливо, занадто безпристрасно - відцентровим силам розірвати нас,
створити ще більшу нерівність і дисбаланс усередині Європи і в підсумку послабити Європу і Німеччину.
Врешті-решт Німеччина вчинила правильно, рятуючи Грецію від виходу з Єврозони і стабілізуючи економіку слабших країн.
Але лише в останній момент. І в результаті хворобливі наслідки виявилися набагато сильнішими,
ніж якби Німеччина діяла раніше і була більш послідовною.
Вона ніколи не була за прості рішення, а завжди за багаторівневі компроміси.
Це було корисно, але вимагало багато часу і, відповідно, багато грошей.
Стихійне лихо в далекій Японії стало причиною швидкого ухвалення Анґелою Меркель вкрай несподіваного рішення.
Коли 11 березня 2011 року цунамі зруйнувало японську атомну електростанцію у Фукусімі і відбувся викид великої кількості радіоактивних речовин,
Анґела Меркель різко змінює курс в галузі енергетики.
Наскільки активно я виступала за продовження термінів експлуатації німецьких атомних електростанцій минулої осені
в межах нашої всеосяжної енергетичної концепції, настільки ж сьогодні я однозначно заявляю перед усіма тут присутніми,
що "Фукусіма" змінила мою позицію щодо атомної енергетики.
Німеччина заявляє, що хоче закрити всі свої атомні електростанції до 2022 року і негайно закриває сім своїх найстаріших реакторів.
Це відповідальне рішення чи поступка громадській думці?
І якими будуть глобальні наслідки того, що Німеччина залишиться без ядерної енергії?
Це було єдине питання, щодо якого вона ухвалила рішення дуже швидко. Занадто швидко, на мій погляд.
Адже вона ніколи не поспішає з рішеннями, але в тій ситуації все сталося дуже швидко, і не було на той момент погоджено з Францією.
Багато хто задається питанням – чи зробила вона це, виходячи зі своїх переконань?
Адже раніше вона сама стверджувала, що не може уявити собі подібну аварію в західній промислово розвиненій країні.
Але мені відомо від людей з її оточення, що для неї ця катастрофа стала справжнім потрясінням.
На початку 2011 року також абсолютно несподівано починаються фундаментальні зміни в арабському світі.
Вітер змін лютує в Північній Африці і на Близькому Сході.
Мільйони людей вимагають свободи, соціальної справедливості та відставки урядів у своїх країнах.
Незабаром демонстранти виходять на вулиці у Лівії та Сирії. Майже весь регіон охоплений протестами.
Арабська весна застала світових лідерів зненацька.
Що стосується "арабської весни", думаю, серйозною помилкою було те, що європейці - Німеччина в цілому і пані Меркель зокрема -
недостатньо підтримали демократію.
Якби вони правильно витлумачили, зрозуміли і підтримали демократичні вимоги туніської, єгипетської і сирійської молоді,
яка вийшла на вулиці набагато раніше, ми б сьогодні, напевно, жили в зовсім іншому світі.
Для мене помилка Анґели Меркель не в тому, як вона відреагувала на арабські революції.
Я думаю, помилка була в тому, що вона не передбачила, якими будуть наслідки, якщо ці революції підуть не так.
У Лівії прагнення до свободи призводить до жорстокого протистояння з владою і насильства.
Правитель Муаммар Каддафі не хоче йти у відставку. Починається громадянська війна.
І перед Європою постає питання: спостерігати за всім цим з боку чи втручатися військовим шляхом?
Рада Безпеки ООН ухвалює рішення про оголошення безпольотної зони, НАТО забезпечує її дотримання.
Меркель виступає проти операції. Німеччина утримується, як і Росія, Китай, Бразилія та Індія.
Німці - поза грою. Вони покинули лави своїх старих європейських союзників і США, коли в ООН обговорювалась ідея зони, забороненої для польотів.
Ми бачимо великі ризики. Імовірність великомасштабних людських жертв не слід недооцінювати.
Протягом семи місяців французькі, британські та американські винищувачі завдають ударів по Лівії.
Каддафі убито, але конфлікт не припиняється. Незабаром країну знову охоплює громадянська війна.
У Сирії також багато хто закликає до зміни влади. Але президент Башар Асад не бажає поступатися, придушує протести
і віддає наказ стріляти в громадян своєї країни.
Сирія перетворюється на арену військових дій. І знову перед Європою виникає питання:
як реагувати на конфлікт? Тим більше що союзником режиму Асада є Росія.
Франція і Великобританія хочуть надати повстанцям військову підтримку. Анґела Меркель знову виступає із застереженням.
Вона вважає, що президент Росії Путін не допустить швидкого краху режиму Асада.
Ми просто повинні бути обережними, щоб іншій стороні не поставляли ще більше зброї країни,
які займають іншу позицію щодо Асада, ніж, наприклад, Німеччина і країни-члени Європейського Союзу.
З гуманітарної точки зору рішення проблеми полягає в тому, щоб покласти край громадянській війні в Сирії.
І змусити режим Асада припинити широкомасштабні репресії щодо власного народу.
Мені видається, що серед іншого перебування Анґели Меркель на посаді канцлерки позначається й тим, що вона завжди уникала силових рішень.
Конфлікт продовжує загострюватися, забираючи дедалі більше життів. Росія продовжує підтримувати режим Асада.
Франція, Великобританія, США і Туреччина хочуть позбутися Асада і готові підтримати повстанців. Країна зазнає тотальної руйнації.
Світові держави не можуть прийти до спільного знаменника з сирійського питання.
Анґела Меркель робить ставку на переговори, але все, що вона може зробити, це лише звертатися із закликами до всіх задіяних сторін.
Мільйони біженців, ця війна принесла вже сотні тисяч жертв, дуже багато жертв, їй слід покласти край.
І досягти цього можна буде лише політичним шляхом.
У неї дуже добра репутація в арабському світі. І головна причина в тому, що Німеччина не бачить себе в ролі
світового поліцейського, що вона не вступає у війни, не каже, що буде вирішувати проблеми, змінювати режими і бомбити.
Німеччина - сильна демократія. І я думаю, що вона є маяком для решти світу в сфері ліберальної демократії,
громадянських свобод, дотримання прав людини, забезпечення стабільності.
Але неможливо продовжувати залишатися таким маяком, якщо сидіти осторонь і не бруднити руки, вирішуючи складні питання безпеки в світі.
Війна в Сирії продовжується, країна розпадається. І незабаром в бунтівних регіонах дедалі більший вплив здобудуть радикальні ісламісти.
Поки Сирія потопає в крові, ще в одній країні - цього разу в Східній Європі - починає розгоратися руйнівний конфлікт.
У 2013 році Європейський Союз пропонує Україні угоду про асоціацію.
Після довгих переговорів тодішній президент України Віктор Янукович відхиляє угоду.
Імовірно, під тиском президента Росії Володимира Путіна, який критично ставиться до зближення України з ЄС.
Путін вимагає від Євросоюзу права участі в ухваленні рішень щодо цього.
Україна опиняється на порозі вирішального випробування. Проєвропейськи налаштовані громадяни хочуть зближення з Європою
і вимагають відставки президента Януковича. Ситуація загострюється, влада намагається придушити протести.
Це призводить до насильства і великої кількості жертв. Янукович змушений втекти до Росії.
Його просто викинули - і все. І без всяких на те юридичних підстав. Ось.
Але це не означає, що ми заперечували проти того, щоб Україна мала якісь просунуті відносини з Європейським Союзом.
Ще раз повторюю: це і так можливо було, швидше за все, провести, але без всяких переворотів.
В Україні далі неспокійно. Проросійські сепаратисти на Сході країни беруть у руки зброю. Судячи з усього, за підтримки Путіна.
Уже в лютому 2014 року, коли Росія анексувала Кримський півострів, встановивши контроль над цим українським регіоном,
відносини Меркель з Путіним також сягають дна. США і ЄС запроваджують санкції проти Росії. Анґела Меркель підтримує цей крок.
Вона була надзвичайно жорсткою щодо санкцій ЄС.
І вона не лише погодилася з ними, але й зробила так, щоб вони були настільки жорсткими, наскільки це було можливо.
Але водночас Меркель не хоче обривати нитку переговорів з Путіним і продовжує шукати рішення кризи.
Бойові дії в Україні тривають. Меркель не опускає руки і разом з Франсуа Олландом ініціює посередницьку місію
з метою прямих переговорів між Києвом і Москвою.
Ви знаєте, у неї є хороша, на мій погляд, риса для переговірника і для ... [пауза] взагалі політичного діяча.
По-перше, вона вміє слухати. По-друге, вона вміє стримуватися. Ось.
Мені здається, це якраз її характеризує найкращим чином.
Тому що, коли людина починає гарячкувати, починає із залізною, якоюсь непробивною прямотою, упертістю доводити свою точку зору -
це точно не сприяє досягненню мети, досягненню якогось компромісу, досягненню взаєморозуміння.
12 лютого 2015 року зусилля увінчалися успіхом - у столиці Білорусі Мінську після довгих переговорів була досягнута домовленість про припинення вогню.
Знову і знову Анґела Меркель наголошує на діалозі і співробітництві замість конфронтації.
Навіть при тому, що більше не має ілюзій щодо політики Володимира Путіна.
Я приїхала сьогодні в Москву в непростий період німецько-російських відносин.
Злочинна анексія Криму, яка суперечить міжнародному праву, а також бойові дії на Сході України завдали важкого удару по цій співпраці.
Важкого, тому що ми бачимо порушення загальноєвропейських основ мирного співіснування.
Меркель каже напряму, називає речі своїми іменами.
Але при цьому усвідомлює, що особливих альтернатив співпраці з Росією немає.
Обійми з главами авторитарних держав. Анґелу Меркель неодноразово звинувачували в цьому під час її канцлерства.
Зближення вона шукає і з Китаєм, наприклад, з головою КНР Сі Цзіньпіном.
Піднебесна з самого початку грала для Анґели Меркель особливу роль у зовнішній політиці.
За останні 16 років вона зробила величезний внесок у німецько-китайські відносини, а також у розширення торгово-економічної діяльності.
Жоден лідер європейської держави не здійснював стільки поїздок до Китаю, скільки вона.
12 разів вона їздила до Китаю - більше, ніж будь-який інший глава уряду Німеччини до неї.
І в центрі уваги завжди стояли економічні інтереси німецьких підприємців, які хочуть робити бізнес в Китаї.
Відповідальність несе не лише пані Меркель, а й великі німецькі, а також французькі компанії, яких не надто цікавлять права людини.
Компанії підштовхують свої уряди до підписання торгових угод, при цьому не звертаючи уваги на права людини.
Іти дружнім до Китаю економічним курсом і при цьому не зрадити своїй системі цінностей – підтримувати такий баланс вкрай складно.
У 2007 році Меркель фактично спровокувала китайську владу, коли прийняла в Берліні Далай-ламу, духовного лідера тибетських буддистів.
Та й в інших випадках вона не скупилася на критику на адресу Пекіна.
Гадаю, ми продовжимо обговорювати права людини на майбутніх зустрічах.
Це включає свободу релігії, це включає свободу висловлювати свою думку.
Права людини і проблеми, пов'язані з ними, є невід'ємною частиною наших переговорів і відносин.
Але й після 16 років перебування Анґели Меркель на посаді канцлерки та після її численних закликів свобода громадян, та й взагалі демократія,
досі не відіграють у Китаї бодай якусь роль.
Демократичний рух у Гонконзі жорстко придушується, практично за всіма ведеться тотальне спостереження, меншини зазнають дискримінації.
Меркель, однак, продовжує виступати за співпрацю і навіть наполягає на укладенні інвестиційної угоди між Європейським Союзом і Китаєм у 2020 році.
Ми повинні визнати один одного, прийняти один одного, працювати разом.
Не можна просто казати: якщо ти не змінишся і не станеш одним з нас, ми зруйнуємо твою репутацію.
Ми будемо тиснути на вас, ми оголосимо вас імперією зла або чимось таким.
У відносинах з Китаєм ми повинні звикнути до того, що він як був, так і залишиться торговельним партнером.
Але ми не повинні бути наївними у відносинах з ним.
Не бути наївним у відносинах з іншими країнами. Навіть у відносинах із союзниками.
Це стало очевидним під час перебування Анґели Меркель при владі.
Канцлерка Німеччини і президент США Барак Обама відразу ж знайшли спільну мову.
Навіть при тому, що між ними не було згоди з усіх політичних питань,
а блискучий оратор Обама і прагматична Меркель здаються вихідцями з різних світів.
Барак Обама теж завжди високо цінував обмін думками з Анґелою Меркель та її аналітичний склад розуму.
Вона завжди була людиною, якій я можу довіряти і яка глибоко вірить в ту роль,
яку Німеччина і всі країни можуть відігравати в тому, щоб зробити кращими не лише наші країни, а й весь світ.
Коли в 2013 році з'ясовується, що АНБ, одна з розвідувальних служб США, стежить за каналами зв'язку Анґели Меркель,
США і Німеччина стикаються з кризою довіри.
З тих пір, як ми почали говорити про АНБ, я також неодноразово давала зрозуміти американському президентові:
шпигунство серед друзів - неприпустиме.
Обама вибачається перед Меркель за прослуховування, про яке, як він стверджує, нічого не знав
і яке, як подейкують, почалося ще за його попередника Буша.
Я, звичайно, поняття не мав, що ми шпигували за Анґелою Меркель.
І так, я думаю, що це не те, що називають дружбою. Вона мала повне право на критику.
Не лише Меркель, а й президентка Бразилії Ділма Русеф стала об'єктом стеження США.
Лідерки двох країн вирішують почати спільні дії проти шпигунства.
"На вихідних президентка Ділма Русеф обговорила безпеку електронних комунікацій з канцлеркою Меркель, за якою також шпигували американці".
Бразилія та Німеччина представили в ООН спільний проєкт резолюції
Що було написано в цьому проєкті? Те, що це дійсно було не лише порушенням прав людини, а й порушенням суверенітету наших країн.
Однак адміністрація Обами позбавляє текст резолюції проти шпигунства гостроти.
Для прагматичної Анґели Меркель очевидно, що у великій політиці доводиться миритися з безліччю розчарувань.
І що відносини з могутнім партнером США є важливішими, ніж прояви чутливості.
У 2014 році терористичне угрупування "Ісламська держава" завойовує дедалі більші регіони в Іраку і Сирії,
вбиваючи і змушуючи до втечі сотні тисяч людей. Царство фанатизму й жаху.
США, Великобританія і Франція намагаються зупинити радикальних ісламських бойовиків і спільно атакують їхні позиції.
У відповідь - ще більше насильства. Цього разу - в Європі.
7 січня 2015 року кілька терористів напали на редакцію сатиричного журналу Charlie Hebdo в Парижі, убивши загалом 12 осіб.
Франція в стані шоку. Анґела Меркель, перебуваючи в цей час з візитом у прем'єр-міністра Великобританії Девіда Кемерона,
відразу запевняє Франсуа Олланда в своїй підтримці.
Я все життя буду дуже вдячний Анґелі Меркель за ту позицію, яку вона зайняла, коли Франція стала жертвою терористичних атак.
У той час Німеччина була нашим найціннішим другом, тому що вона продемонструвала свою підтримку цілою низкою жестів.
Це і поїздка Анґели Меркель до Парижа - вона взяла на себе ініціативу і першою долучилась до великої демонстрації 11 січня.
Це і наша співпраця в боротьбі з терористами.
Все це було дуже важливо для французько-німецьких відносин,
для особистих відносин між мною і пані Меркель.
І думаю, що характер цих відносин не буде втрачено ніколи.
Улітку 2015 року канцлерка зіткнулася зі своїм найсерйознішим викликом.
Війна в Сирії та інші кризи змусили мільйони людей полишити свої домівки.
Мільйони біженців вирушили в напрямку Європи.
А потім був караван цих найбільш знедолених у світі людей, які за допомогою контрабандистів на човнах,
що ледве тримаються на воді, намагалися дістатися до Греції, Італії тощо.
І куди б вони не прибували, двері перед ними захлопували.
Усі зачиняли свої кордони, аби запобігти напливу мігрантів.
Вона зробила сміливий крок - встала і сказала: "Я маю намір відчинити кордони і впустити цих людей".
Вона знала, що ризикує, роблячи це.
Наш обов'язок полягає і в наданні захисту тим, хто його потребує.
Сотні тисяч сирійців, рятуючись від бомб, рятуючись від гноблення, якимось чином добираються до Європи,
а потім біжать до Німеччини, скандуючи "Німеччина, Німеччина…"
Це не європейська проблема, це проблема німецька. Ніхто з них не хоче залишатися в Угорщині.
Угорщина в Європі - приклад найгіршої реакції на потік біженців, в той час як Німеччина - найкращої.
І ось тепер Франція і Великобританія оголосили, що вони нібито приймуть 24 тисячі і 20 тисяч біженців відповідно.
Щоправда, впродовж декількох років, зауважте, в той час як Німеччина прийняла 17 тисяч осіб лише за один день минулого тижня. За один день!
Німеччина - сильна країна. І настрій, з яким ми підходимо до цих речей, повинен бути...
Нам так багато вже вдалося, ми впораємося!
Я знаю, що це рішення далося канцлерці Меркель нелегко. Для ухвалення цього рішення потрібно багато мужності -
і політичної, і громадянської, і віри у власні переконання.
Я думаю, що це була велика політична помилка. Вона недооцінила небезпеку неконтрольованої міграції.
Те, що вона це допустила, призвело до вкрай неприємної реакції, популістської реакції.
Наприкінці літа 2015 року дедалі більше людей у Німеччині виходять на вулиці проти політики Анґели Меркель щодо біженців.
Якщо нам тепер доведеться вибачатися за те, що ми дружньо ставимося до людей у скрутній ситуації, то це не моя країна.
Їй потрібно було це витримати як політику. У той час її ненавиділи в багатьох верствах німецького суспільства.
Істинний державний діяч - це той, хто кидає виклик протидії всередині країни, і вона зробила це. Велика жінка!
Одні прославляють Анґелу Меркель як політика з великим серцем. Для інших вона стає мішенню для нападок.
Її політика зустрічає опір і в Європі. Меркель шукає союзників - країни, які були б готові прийняти більше шукачів притулку.
Закликає до загальноєвропейської політики щодо біженців.
Але знайти партнерів виявляється непросто. Країни Східної Європи, зокрема, взагалі майже відмовляються приймати біженців.
Глави урядів країн Євросоюзу поспіхом збираються в Брюсселі, щоб знайти рішення.
І, незважаючи на всі розбіжності, сходяться в одному: щоб стримати потік біженців, необхідно підтримати країну,
яка вже давно змушена справлятися з цією проблемою самотужки: а саме - Туреччину.
За дорученням ЄС в жовтні 2015 року Анґела Меркель їде до Стамбула.
Тепер надія на турецький уряд під керівництвом прем'єр-міністра Ахмета Давутоглу.
Туреччина, а також сусідні Йорданія і Ліван несли на своїх плечах тягар утримання цих біженців протягом п'яти років.
Європейські лідери і пані Меркель в тому числі розглядали цю кризу як щось, що відбувається десь далеко.
Вони намагалися зупинити приплив біженців на кордонах з Туреччиною і в односторонньому порядку очікували, що Туреччина буде займатися тим же.
Але тепер все повинно бути по-іншому. Анґела Меркель зустрічається з істинним правителем Туреччини, президентом Реджепом Ердоганом.
Перш за все вона повинна переконати його не пускати більше біженців до ЄС.
Серед іншого вона пропонує фінансову допомогу від Євросоюзу і відкриває перспективу спрощення візового режиму для турецьких громадян.
У березні 2016 року представники Туреччини і Євросоюзу досягають згоди.
З цього моменту до Європи прибуває дедалі менше людей з кризових регіонів,
попри те, що сотні тисяч продовжують тікати від насильства й злиднів і скупчуються в таборах для біженців.
Тим часом у Великобританії зростає невдоволення Євросоюзом.
Багато британців хочуть більшої незалежності їхньої країни від європейських структур і виступають проти прийняття біженців.
Їхня мета - вихід Великобританії з об'єднаної Європи. Брекзіт.
На початку 2016 року прем'єр-міністр Великобританії Девід Кемерон зажадав від інших членів ЄС зробити винятки для його країни -
особливо щодо імміграційної політики. Він їх отримує.
Значною мірою і завдяки сприянню Анґели Меркель, яка хоче будь-якою ціною втримати британців у Євросоюзі.
У червні 2016 року британці мають ухвалити рішення на референдумі - покинути ЄС або залишитися в ньому.
Нагнітання страху перед біженцями й імміграцією - основний інструмент політиків, які домагаються Брекзіта.
Колега Кемерона по партії Борис Джонсон теж використовує популістські гасла в кампанії за припинення членства в ЄС.
23 червня 2016 року з незначною перевагою перемагають прихильники Брекзіта. Анґела Меркель не приховує свого розчарування.
З великим жалем ми змушені сьогодні взяти до відома рішення більшості британців
про бажання припинити членство Сполученого Королівства в Європейському Союзі.
Думаю, що Брекзіт був і залишається для них дуже сильним ударом, і вона намагалися зробити все можливе, щоб його уникнути.
Націоналізм бере гору над європейським співробітництвом. Поразка для Анґели Меркель. І для ідеї об'єднаної Європи.
У 2016 році на політичній сцені з'являється новий президент США Дональд Трамп.
Ми збираємося перемогти Китай, Японію, ми збираємося перемогти Мексику. А брехлива преса намагається змусити нас замовчати.
...який робить ставку на підтримку забобонів і націоналізм.
Це буде означати - тільки Америка понад усе! Америка понад усе!
Ставши президентом, Дональд Трамп ставить під сумнів не лише глобальну співпрацю, а й ліберальні цінності.
Анґела Меркель опиняється у вкрай скрутному становищі.
Адже могутні США залишаються одним з найважливіших партнерів Німеччини.
Через два місяці після приведення до присяги Дональд Трамп запрошує канцлерку Німеччини в Білий дім.
Меркель хоче уникнути відкритої конфронтації з Трампом.
Але відомий своєю ексцентричною поведінкою президент США і стримана та вдумлива канцлерка - це різні світи.
Дональд Трамп зневажає Анґелу Меркель. Я не можу пригадати жодного іншого прикладу, коли політик настільки гаряче зневажав іншого.
Він просто не знав, як поводитися з Меркель.
Йому не подобалася її суперраціональність,
він не міг дати собі раду з її самовладанням,
йому здавалося дуже підозрілим те, що вона не висловлювалася настільки ж вульгарно, як він.
Але вкотре Меркель намагається налагодити спілкування з важким партнером.
Набагато краще говорити один з одним, ніж один про одного.
Проте Дональд Трамп бере курс на конфронтацію. Він виводить США з угоди ООН щодо захисту клімату,
за яку довгий час боролася Меркель, і вимагає від партнерів по НАТО, особливо від Німеччини, збільшення видатків на оборону.
Навіть якщо обидва політики і не завжди дають це зрозуміти - відносини між ФРН і США здаються гіршими за всю їхню історію.
Часи, коли ми могли повністю покластися один на одного, - вони частково позаду.
Анґела Меркель виглядає прямою протилежністю американського президента - демократичним і ліберальним полюсом спокою.
Через чотири роки Дональд Трамп залишає міжнародну арену.
Зміна клімату ніколи не хвилювала Дональда Трампа.
А ось для Анґели Меркель боротьба з глобальним потеплінням від початку була одним з наріжних каменів її політики.
На саміті "Великої вісімки" в Гайлігендаммі в 2007 році вона спробувала зобов'язати основних виробників парникових газів скоротити викиди.
Але натрапила на опір.
Анґела дуже активно виступала за екологію. У мене немає претензій до неї в зв'язку з цим.
І я розумів суть питання, просто не хотів глобального договору, в якому б не брали участь Китай та Індія. Це було б марною тратою часу.
Хоч гості Меркель і згодні з тим, що шкідливі викиди треба скорочувати, ніхто не хоче брати на себе жодних зобов'язань.
В підсумковій декларації у Гайлігендаммі наголошувалося: "Ми серйозно розглядаємо можливість скорочення
викидів парникових газів удвічі до середини століття".
У мене було таке відчуття, що мене схопить удар.
Тому що, як ви розумієте, ця заява насправді не означає буквально нічого.
А потім ЗМІ почали звеличувати її як "канцлерку-захисницю клімату". Але це звання вона так і не виправдала.
Меркель намагається подати добрий приклад іншим країнам.
У 2007 році її уряд ухвалює рішення скоротити викиди парникових газів на 40 відсотків до 2020 року -
в тому числі за рахунок підвищення податків на автомобілі з високими витратами пального.
Але німецькі автовиробники чинять запеклий опір.
Автомобілі для Німеччини - експортний товар номер один, автопром є потужним роботодавцем.
Анґела Меркель не може – або, зрештою, не хоче - кардинально міняти цю впливову галузь.
Її заслуги в енергетичній сфері теж неоднозначні.
З одного боку, за час її канцлерства частка відновлюваних джерел енергії збільшилася з 10 до 46 відсотків.
Але з іншого - в Німеччині досі не закриті найшкідливіші для екології електростанції, що працюють на вугіллі,
і середньостатистичний німець виробляє занадто багато вуглекислого газу в глобальному порівнянні.
Такій промислово розвиненій країні як Німеччина, безумовно, має сенс ставити перед собою масштабні кліматичні цілі.
Зрештою, ми повинні показати, що економічне процвітання і захист клімату не суперечать одне одному.
І я вважаю, що це був би важливий сигнал для всього світу. І ніхто не зміг би сказати:
"Ні, як промислово розвинена країна ми не можемо впоратися з такою трансформацією". Ми могли б домогтися цього.
Потепління триває. Нове покоління закликає політиків діяти. Анґела Меркель згодна.
Принаймні з точки зору риторики вона залишається вірною цілям щодо захисту клімату до самого кінця свого канцлерства.
Вона дуже емоційна. У цьому плані вона від щирого серця вірить, що на кону дійсно стоїть існування людства.
З іншого боку, вона прагматик до мозку кісток і усвідомлює, що можна реально просунути на практиці, а що ні.
І саме тому підсумок її діяльності в цьому напрямку не був дуже значним.
Ще одна глобальна загроза - така ж невидима, як парниковий газ.
Суміш природних сил і людського чинника.
Наприкінці 2019 року в китайському місті Ухань з'являється новий вид небезпечного вірусу і з шаленою швидкістю поширюється по цілому світу.
Мільйони людей хворіють, багато хто вмирає.
Після перших вагань Анґела Меркель звертається до громадськості зі зворшуливою промовою.
Шановні співгромадяни, коронавірус змінює нині життя в нашій країні кардинально.
Наші уявлення про нормальне суспільне життя, соціальність - все це піддається випробуванню, як ніколи раніше.
Федеральний уряд вдається до радикальних кроків.
Змушені закритися підприємства, а також заклади в галузі культури, ресторани й магазини.
Люди зобов'язані уникати контактів. Тому що від вірусу немає ані ліків, ані вакцин.
Гадаю, вона зробила те, що повинна була зробити.
Вона одна з тих, хто відразу ж почав вживати рішучих дій, і я думаю, що це дійсно спрацювало.
Якщо ви просто поглянете на останні півтора року, то країни, на чолі яких стоять жінки, впоралися з пандемією набагато краще, ніж решта.
Тим не менше, надто багато людей помирає. Соціальні та економічні збитки високі. У Німеччині і в цілому світі.
Багато галузей економіки змушені зупинити свою діяльність на кілька місяців.
Євросоюзу знову загрожує серйозна економічна криза.
І подальша втрата довіри серед громадян.
Щоб запобігти цьому, Анґела Меркель і президент Франції Еммануель Макрон закликають до того, від чого Меркель відмовилася десять років тому:
до спільних позик для всіх країн ЄС для підтримки економіки.
У всіх кризах, через які пройшла Європа, вона представляла інтереси Європи.
Коли в середині серпня 2021 року радикальний рух "Талібан" майже без бою захоплює столицю Афганістану Кабул,
амбітний проєкт США і задіяних у ньому союзників, у тому числі й ФРН, раптово закінчується.
20-річний конфлікт, в якому брала участь Німеччина, наздоганяє Анґелу Меркель незадовго до закінчення її канцлерського терміну.
Це більш ніж гірка подія. Це трагедія і, звичайно, такий розвиток подій особливо жахливий для народу Афганістану -
країни, з якою так жорстоко обходилися і обходяться протягом всієї її історії.
З кінця 2001-го німецький Бундесвер разом з іншими військами НАТО
був дислокований в Афганістані для підтримки США в боротьбі проти "Талібану" та терористичного угрупування "Аль-Каїда".
Вважалося, що західні війська принесуть Афганістану більше безпеки, а також сприятимуть дотриманню прав людини,
прав жінок та демократичному розвитку країни. Конфлікт забрав загалом понад 200 тисяч життів.
Було помилкою затягувати операцію на 20 років без чіткого плану стабілізації Афганістану -
стабілізації, я не кажу демократизації, я не кажу модернізації, а просто стабілізації.
Коли Анґела Меркель стає канцлеркою в 2005 році, німецькі військовослужбовці вже перебувають в Афганістані.
Вона відвідує контингент кілька разів. І завжди підтримує і виправдовує місію, в ході якої загинули 59 солдатів Бундесверу.
Коли президент США Дональд Трамп оголосив у лютому 2020 року про намір вивести американські війська з Афганістану,
стало ясно, що всі інші іноземні солдати незабаром теж покинуть країну.
Новий президент США Джо Байден продовжує термін до вересня 2021 року,
але вже за кілька місяців до цього таліби починають завойовувати одну провінцію за одною.
Так закінчується місія, здійснити яку 20 років тому наказав інший президент США.
Я думаю про всіх перекладачів і людей, які допомагали не лише військам США, але й НАТО.
І схоже, що їх просто залишать на розтерзання цим жорстоким людям.
Безліч афганців, які співпрацювали з Бундесвером та іншими арміями країн НАТО, місяцями просять візу.
Але багатьом відмовляють або просто не дають можливості виїхати з Афганістану.
Ніхто не міг спати спокійно з усвідомленням того, що це стало результатом цього жахливо непродуманого виведення військ.
Західні війська покинули Афганістан, зруйнований і відданий до рук талібів.
16-річна епоха Меркель добігає кінця.
16 років, протягом яких світу і канцлерці Німеччини довелося долати безліч випробувань.
Це, як і раніше, видатне досягнення - утримати всіх в цій крамничці разом, та ще й протягом, ймовірно, найважчих років, які пережила об'єднана Європа.
Її не вистачатиме. Але й у неї буде багато роботи. Ми не хочемо, щоб вона йшла. Вона буде покровителькою всіх жінок світу.
Упевнений: спадщиною Анґели Меркель буде й те, що багато дівчат подивляться на неї і скажуть:
"Я теж можу займати таку відповідальну і впливову посаду". Адже вона тримала себе з такою гідністю.
Справжня суть канцлерства Меркель - це стагнація. Метою було залишити все як є, тому що німці були задоволені шляхом, по якому йшли.
Я, напевно, пам'ятатиму про неї до самої смерті. Але ось, боюся, історією вона буде забута,
тому що в неї не було бачення майбутнього для Європи або Німеччини.
Вона зробила багато правильного і жодної істотної помилки. І це не якийсь маленький комплімент.
Я обов'язково зроблю перерву, під час якої подумаю про те, що ж мене особисто, власне, цікавить.
Тому що останні 16 років у мене було дуже мало часу на це.
А потім я спробую що-небудь почитати, потім мої очі закриються, тому що я втомилася, потім я трохи посплю, а потім...
Побачимо, де я з'явлюся.